[Musik]
mark zuckerbergs war ein harvard neuling
mit einer begabung fürs programmieren
weniger als ein jahrzehnt später als
lehrer multimilliardär mit dem baby
gesicht bau der mit dem präsident nicht
zusammen
und ich habe mark dazu gebracht hat und
krawatte zu tragen
ich glaube die meisten leute haben die
größe von facebook noch nicht wirklich
verstanden und wie schnell es gewachsen
ist das ziel ist offensichtlich eine
allgegenwart mark zuckerberg möchte dass
alle diesen service nutzen er das
wohnheim projekt zum größten globalen
dorf des index die seite hat
mittlerweile über 900 millionen nutzer
man kann nicht unterschätzen wie
getrieben sagte burke ist er ist genauso
visionär steve jobs
kürzlich als genauso einflussreich
erweisen wie bill gates trotz des
erfolgs lieferte sich sachsenburg
erbitterte kämpfe
er wollte sein eigenes ding
kontrollieren und wenn er gegen jemanden
vorgeht wenn sie den vermissten wir
haben drei monate mit marc gearbeitet
und wurden hier das licht geführt wir
hatten keine ahnung dass er an einem
konkurrenzprodukt arbeit er hat einen
totalen krieg gegen seine größten
konkurrenten
die beziehung zwischen facebook und
google ist ziemlich einfach sie mögen
sich einfach nicht und zuckerberg geriet
unter beschuss weil er die grenzen der
privatsphäre nutzer haben weniger
kontrolle über private informationen sie
wissen nicht genau wie ihre infos
weitergegeben werden handelt nicht nur
mit einem stück technik er handelt mit
menschen und ihrem verhalten und das
ohne viel darüber nachzudenken
sie haben diese riesige datenbank mit
informationen über uns angehäuft weil
wir ihnen vertraut haben die frage ist
also sollen wir ihnen weiter vertrauen
[Musik]
ich glaube unser ziel war keine online
community sondern eine art spiegel der
echten gemeinschaft den wirklichen leben
existiert monas zuckerberg wir denken
wir kennen ihn beide sein leben im oscar
prämierten film the social network
gesehen das porträt war schonungslos
einen super nerd halsabschneider
brillant aber sozial ich verstehe nicht
welchem teil aber stimmte das auch immer
freunde er ist ein ziemlich sozialer typ
ich glaube das letzte mal habe ich 879
freunde auf facebook an
das hier ist der wahre mark zuckerberg
2005 in facebooks ernster zentrale von
jungen filmemachern getroffen
wir haben drei
millionen nutzer und seit wann gibt es
facebook nicht so lange
währen zuckerberg die privatsphäre der
nutzer ausreizt entschied er sich gegen
die teilnahme an unserem programm
2004 gründete er facebook im alter von
19 jahren mit facebook inzwischen hat
der 28-jährige ein geschätztes vermögen
von 15 5 milliarden dollar angehäuft
max mission war von anfang an menschen
zu verbinden sie basierte auf diese
theorie dass die welt ein besserer ort
wäre wenn sie stärker verbunden wäre
aber es gibt viele überraschungen wenn
man wirklich tief in die geschichte von
facebook eintaucht die größte ist die
eigenwillige persönlichkeit von mark
zuckerberg
die tiefe seiner überzeugungen
[Musik]
1984 geboren wuchs er in jobs terry am
hudson aus in einer wohnsiedlung
nördlich von new york city david
kirkpatrick recherchierte zwei jahre
lang für ein buch über sascha burg und
facebook mit dem titel the facebook
effect er stammt aus einer unglaublichen
unterstützenden familie in der er der
einzige sohn war er hat drei schwestern
also war er eine art drin ich glaube
seine eltern haben ihn sogar den prinzen
genannt und er wurde dementsprechend
behandelt er ist ein typ ohne probleme
mit dem selbstvertrauen computer talent
von anfang an brachte sich sascha bert
die komplizierte computersprache sieg in
der neunten klasse entwickelte er eine
digitale version des brettspiels risiko
antonio vargas interviewte zuckerberg
für sein new yorker magazin profil
tatsächlich angewandt sagt ned
geschaffen hernes instant messaging
system für die familie damit wie
computer miteinander reden konnten
so ein kind gewesen
als er seine highschool satt hatte
beschloss er auf die exit school zu
gehen wirklich weil er einfach mehr
herausforderungen wollte in der
exklusiven exeter erstellten zuckerberg
und sein freund adam die angelo eine
musik website
sie sollte so sein dass sie deine
vorlieben erkennt und sie war sehr
beliebt noch bevor er mit facebook
anfiel
er lehnte angebote von microsoft und
anderen ups in apps für weit über eine
million dollar zu verkaufen
viele namhafte unternehmen wollten ihn
direkt aus exeter rekrutieren sie eine
tech version eines pollstar athleten bei
dem wasserwerk war unbeeindruckt und
entschied sich 2002 statt dessen für
harvard
wo ist nicht lange dauert bis er
probleme bekam zuckerberg hatte sich in
die computer der uni und bilder von
schülern zusammen mika das carls
stellvertretender redakteur bei business
insider dot com
ein bisschen am ingolstädter
er hat in seinem ersten jahr in harvard
etwas erfunden das facemash als eine art
horton noch für die uni und dann führte
die seite eine ganze liste von harvard
studenten welche die attraktivsten waren
nach schönheit erzählt
für das magazin fast company
war irgendwie ein bisschen eklig ist
verärgerte die leute offensichtlich
fühlten sie sich verspottet oder
bloßgestellt
es war eine der ersten großen
erfahrungen die mark mit
datenschutzproblem macht
schloss die seit
die harvard verwaltung klagte ihn wegen
sicherheitsverletzung verletzung von
urheberrechten und verletzung der
privatsphäre
aber facemash war zu dem zeitpunkt schon
eine campus sensation
zur gleichen zeit als er ärger mit
dieser fiesen webseite bekam baute er
ein anderes dieses tool das super clip
war
ich kann mir vorstellen dass ein paar
schlaflose nächte hatte und sich sorgen
machte wie schlimm diese sache werden
würde
war erleichtert als alles vorbei war und
war aber auch unglaublich neugierig was
er als nächstes machen könnte wenn du
ein genie mit genialen freundin bist und
in irgend einem schlafsaal sitzt sieht
die welt wie ein großer glücklicher ort
aus wenn er in diese datenbank kommst
die welt der datenbanken veränderte sich
damals rasant
weiter bei der bloomberg businessweek
das internet trat 2004 eine ganz andere
welt an fenster sieht man dass ein
soziales netzwerk technisch
funktionieren muss die seite hängt sich
immer auch sie ist unzuverlässig auch
myspace folge werbung das lenkt ab und
sie ist auch technisch instabil
lernte zuckerberg den schülern
zukünftigen geschäftspartner
ist einer der wenigen teams über die
anfänge von facebook interviewt haben
traf mark zuckerberg bei einer jüdischen
bruderschaft
in harvard war nicht wirklich lustig es
war eine etwas seltsame soziale umgebung
nicht schlechte partys meistens nur
jungs so trafen sich in dieser szene und
sie wurden ziemlich schnell freuen sie
beide eine art außenseiter waren
wurden drei oberschicht jungs auf
zuckerberg aufmerksam die eine social
network
eine idee die ich ende 2002 als
die drei bastelten seit fast einem jahr
an der seite zwei ihrer programmierer
waren abgesprungen
und sie brauchten dringend einen neuen
partner
wir sind keine computer programmierer
von beruf oder so wir brauchten einen
echten programmierer um das wir uns zu
schreiben
und wir dachten mag wäre dieser türkei
also gingen sie auf sascha bis
zuckerberg
er war begeistert aufgeregt und seine
augen strahlten
wolf dann geschah müsste einen
erbitterten streit darüber aus wie
facebook eigentlich entstanden war
zwischen berg und dem harvard connection
zu
beginn wasserburg noch dank eigentlich
ich habe eure sachen gelesen und ich
denke die umsetzung sollte nicht allzu
lange dauern können darüber reden wenn
ich morgen abend alles hochgefahren habe
dann fing zuckerberg an das projekt zu
verzögern das gitter dezember
entschuldigt dass ich nicht erreichbar
war ich hab gerade euere verpassten
anrufe gesehen ich habe an einem problem
gearbeitet zehnter dezember die woche
war ziemlich stressig konnte noch nicht
wirklich an der seite arbeiten oder
darüber nachdenken
so bürgerte war damit beschäftigt war an
einer ähnlichen social network seite zu
arbeiten die auf dem studenten
verzeichnis von java basierte
und zerrinnt haben sich zusammen um sie
zu finanzieren
kam zu ihm und sagte weißt du
investierst 1000 dollar und
wissen es gab keine verträge das waren
wirklich nur zwei kinder in einem
schlafsaal
interviewte mehr als ein dutzend leute
die an der gründung und facebook
beteiligt war und er entdeckte sofort
nachrichten die zuckerberg am semmering
geschrieben laut business insider deuten
die nachrichten an dass zuckerberg die
winklevoss-zwillinge bewusst in die irre
er schrieb dinge wie guck dir diese
seite an harvard connection h wir haben
fehler gemacht die haben mich gebeten
dass für sie zu machen ich arbeite an
meinem eigenen facebook wir hatten immer
den eindruck dass markt an harvard
connection dot com arbeitet
dass er das nicht tut oder nicht tun
wollte oder an etwas identischem
arbeitete auf der seite
als er sich das letzte mal mit den
winklevoss brüdern traf begriff er dass
er ihn wohl sagen sollte dass er an
einem konkurrenzprodukt saß er hat mit
freunden darüber gesprochen aber ende
sagte er weißt du was ich mache ich lass
sie abblitzen ich wirklich ab
februar 2004 als er eigentlich ihre
seite fertig stellen sollte brachte
sascha burg mit seinen freunden
auf facebook
erfuhren das war genau so wie fast alle
anderen
es hat uns komplett überrumpelt damit
haben wir nicht gerechnet
montag wollte die kontrolle über sein
eigenes projekt haben er sah dass sie
etwas cooles vor hatten die
winklevoss-brüder aber er sagt dass er
etwas kühleres machen können dagegen
jemanden vorgeht wenn ihr für mich getan
sorgte von anfang an für kontroversen
nur wenige tage nach dem start im
februar 2004 schickten ihn die
winklevoss zwillinge und die firma
wensauer eine unterlassungsaufforderung
er uns gesagt klagten wir gegen mark
zuckerberg wegen betrugs
ungerechtfertigter bereicherung und
vertragsbruchs
seine seite sei ein separates
unternehmen für uns
verwendeten später einen 65 millionen
dollar vergleich mit facebook an sie
verloren vor einem bundesgericht war
zwar dieser vergleich könnte jetzt 200
millionen dollar wert sein doch keines
dieser juristischen gerangel bremste so
unglaubliche dynamik von facebook dass
facebook zu diesem zeitpunkt dachten
meine mitbewohner das ist ziemlich cool
ich lasse das wurde auch an anderen
schulen funktionieren also haben wir es
nicht
stanford eine und innerhalb von wenigen
wochen hatten die tausende von nutzern
und wir sagen lasst uns einfach mal
gucken in wie vielen schwulen wie die
seite noch so schnell wie möglich
starten können
zu diesem zeitpunkt begannen sie sich
mit risikokapitalgeber und größeren
werbetreibenden zu treffen
sie bekamen einen ziemlich grünen ziehen
mit visa und sie hatten einen deal mit
american express
sie hatten eine reihe von
werbetreibenden und gingen dann begannen
plattenfirmen sich zu interessieren und
sie erzielten ziemlich gute einnahmen
aus der musikindustrie
shawn parker seine eigene verbindung
auf einer reise nach new york
zuckerberg und sein partner
mit dem 24-jährigen mitbegründer von
netzwerken zu abend essen ein
gestandener unternehmer und ein wirklich
kreative außergewöhnlich interessanter
mensch der es ins netzwerk in silicon
valley geschafft hatte so dass man
einfach sterben könnte
nicht
von anfang an nicht viel von schon in
der dachte schon sein quacksalber
bräuchten spuckt große töne lebe aber
aus dem seesack und sei aus zwei firmen
aus geschmissen worden
wir sind diesen sommer nach palo alto
ist so ein mythischer ort wo alles und
wir haben zu beginn des jahres den start
150 weiteren schub
durch den wechsel nach palo alto -
wirklich in die petrischale der
unternehmen kik vor allem für neue
technologien zuckerberg und seine
freunde zogen in ein großes fachwerkhaus
im schwimmbad und ertrag wieder auf sean
parker
jeweils er war ein aufseher für
erwachsene hieß es gibt er ihm gezeigt
hat wie die dinge im silicon valley
laufen dies wird ihnen gezeigt wie man
investoren trifft wie man mit ihnen
verhandelt und im
magistrat hat mir geschichten von all
den jungs erzählt die spätnachts am
esstisch harry programmieren und chicken
mcnuggets und müsli essen
wo es wirklich schon parker bringt sie
zu den anderen coolen silicon valley
hotspots und währenddessen wächst die
website astronomischen ich meine im
dezember dieses jahres hatten sie eine
million
kaká hat zuckerberg in dieser zeit viele
ratschläge gegeben weil er sich zu
herzen sein an und sagte du musst der
gründer dieser sache sein du musst immer
der ceo sein was du kannst das nicht an
investoren abgeben
und konnte einige sehr wichtige
investitionsabkommen aushandeln die zwei
dinge bewirken
sie gaben ihm genügend mittel um die
klügsten ingenieure der branche
einzustellen und zweitens er konnte die
mehrheit am unternehmen behalten
doch die spannungen mit seinem
ursprünglichen partner eduardo saverin
der an der ostküste geblieben waren
wurden immer größer
er fühlte sich als kaufmännischer leiter
des unternehmens wurde aber nicht mehr
so behandelt und schon hat meetings in
ganz kalifornien und ignorieren
und dann recht
aufmerksamkeit und mark unterwegs
unternehmen
hatte eine million aktive nutzer an
universitäten im ganzen land und es
begann viel geld
der neue präsident von facebook stellte
zuckerberg dem silicon valley angel
investor peter thiel vor der 500.000
dollar in das unternehmen steckte im
frühjahr 2005 bot die venture capital
gesellschaft wechsel partners zuckerberg
12,7 millionen dollar für eine 11
sie waren überhaupt mit für kontrolle
kontrollierte jetzt drei von fünf
vorstand sitzen
besaß ist eine bizarre und beispiellose
situation
wenn eine person die absolute
diktatorische kontrolle über die
aufstellung und leitung eines zunehmend
riesigen unternehmens hat
die excel investition brachte facebook
über nacht eine bewertung von 100
millionen dollar
mit dem öffentlichen profil von facebook
wuchs auch sascha brox machten tro
dieses mal wurde sean parker verdrängt
im august 2005 wurde er wegen des
verdachts des kokainbesitzes
obwohl er nicht offiziell angeklagt und
sofort freigelassen wurde führte dies zu
seinem sofortigen rücktritt
auf facebook
der wichtigste repräsentant des
unternehmens aber man war der meinung
dass jemand der mit drogen zu tun hatte
nicht der richtige typ war um facebook
nach außen zu vertreten also stimmte
mark widerstrebend seiner entlassung zu
wuchs mit bemerkenswerter
geschwindigkeit und zuckerberg verlegte
das unternehmen von seiner studentenbude
mit dem pool in einen größeren und
konventionelleren raum in der innenstadt
von palo alto
aber die colleges atmosphäre blieb
dieselbe sein
der dinge auf die ich mich bei facebook
konzentriere ist dass die kultur
freundliche und die läuterung in sachen
verwaltung des ganzen prozesses
nichts ich hatte keine ahnung was ich
tue
auch ihre mitarbeitergespräche waren
anders chris kelly wurde in der neuen
position des chief privacy officer
eingestellt um sich mit den zunehmend
schwierigen datenschutz themen bei
facebook zu befassen also einer zeit als
das gesamte unternehmen nur ein paar
dutzend mitarbeiter hat
als ich mag zum ersten mal traf
kletterten wir durch das fenster auf
stark und führten unsere interview auf
dem dach eines weltverbesserung
die firma für junge leute
entschlossen die ungewöhnlich kreative
kultur von facebook zu erhalten waren
programmieren echte eine möglichkeit das
zu tun wir haben diese meetings in der
firma wo alle zusammen kommen und
einfach irgendwas zu trainieren die
ganze nacht was born und die einzige
regel ist dass man bei dem treffen nicht
an dem aber im davor ansonsten arbeiten
die leute an verrückten
waren einst der kreativsten dinge die
man sich in einem unternehmen vorstellen
konnte da kommen diese unglaublich
talentierten ingenieure zusammen und
sagen wir bleiben die ganze nacht wir
programmieren einfach wir suchen uns ein
projekt
das ist toll macht auf wir machen einen
prototypen daraus dann gibt's einen
krieg und wir sehen wer gewinnt
vom aus marktsicht entstehen auf diese
weise gute ideen schnell und effizient
des kabels gute ideen und sack aber
führte etwas ein dass facebook einen
plötzlichen und dramatischen schub gab
es ermöglichte den leuten und sich und
ihre freunde auf fotos zu identifizieren
oder zu markieren
das war eine riesige umstellung das
führte zu einer massiven neuen nutzung
von facebook
fotos waren sehr schnell der bei weitem
am meisten genutzte teil von facebook
facebook ein hund der größte
wachstumstreiber
dieses wachstum ging in eine richtung
nach oben laut facebook internem
tracking wuchs die zahl der nutzer in
weniger als zwei jahren auf 5,5
millionen
mediengiganten hämmerten an die tür
2006 machte yahoo dem 22-jährigen
zuckerberg ein außergewöhnliches angebot
offen bei auch für eine milliarde dollar
dort
noch außergewöhnlicher zuckerberg lehnte
ab
wenn sie eltern von jemandem in marcs
alter sind sie sich die yahoo
entscheidung an und denken warum hast du
das geld nicht genommen
wenn es so wäre wäre es einfach
ausverkaufte haben ich habe einfach das
gefühl dass es uns nicht dabei helfen
wurde facebook zu dem zu machen was wir
uns vorstellen
2006 lehnte mark zuckerberg einen
milliardenschweren pitch von yahoo als
mtv den einsatz noch höheren trieben
hecke mehr nur mark hatte mich auf einen
spaziergang durch palo alto mitgenommen
und mir seine wohnung gezeigt
dann gingen wir mit
und ich sagte ihm dass wir bereit wären
bis zu anderthalb milliarden dollar zu
zahlen
eine antwort war ich denke wir sind viel
mehr wert und außerdem hast du meine
wohnung gesehen wie viel geld brauche
ich plane man ihn vielleicht habe ich
nie wieder eine so gute idee
ich will nicht wirklich
ob es innere unruhen keine frage es gab
viele leute die verkaufen wollten markt
beschloss einfach diese angebote
abzulehnen
zuckerberg war noch nicht bereit zu
verkaufen weil er einige ideen hatte von
denen er dachte dass sie facebook noch
bekannter machen würden eine von ihnen
hieß newsfeed eine art
echtzeitnachrichten uns darüber was die
nutzer gerade tun
newsfeed ist was jemand gerade tut oder
was er kostet und mit der welt verbindet
in der erlebt also etwas das eine
zeitung tut es wird es ist eine
lebendige atmen bezahlung von menschen
um dich herum aber viele facebook-nutzer
dachten dass diese zeitung zu viele
informationen verschickt und ihre
privatsphäre verletzt
750000 von ihnen starteten einen online
protest zu sagen dass es unpopulär war
es eine dramatische untertreibung sie
wurden im büro belagert sie konnten
nicht gewöhnt sie waren von reportern
der
nutzer schlossen sich den studenten
gegen die facebook newsfeed gruppe an
so aber musste sich entschuldigen
er hat seine entschuldigung selbst
geschrieben es war wahrscheinlich eine
gute lernerfahrung als facebook einige
der datenschutz einstellungen ändern es
war eine überschreitung ich glaube er
nimmt das ernst aber ich glaube dass er
bereit ist weiter zu gehen um ein
produkt herzustellen dass er herstellen
möchte
die entschuldigung war keine
kapitulation
zuckerberg war sich sicher dass sich die
nutzer an diese neue art des teilens
gewöhnen würden und er behielt recht
hast du nach der optimierung des
newsfeed wurde es zu einem der
beliebtesten elemente
[Musik]
erstes treffen mit marc war zufällig
zwei tage nach dem was passiert war und
ich kann ihnen sagen obwohl seine
mitglieder in aufruhr waren war er nicht
im geringsten
er hatte volles vertrauen dass alles gut
gehen würde
zuckerberg entschied dass es an der zeit
sei facebook über die uni grenzen hinaus
zu führen und der breiten öffentlichkeit
vorzustellen
die resonanz war die mitgliederzahl
verdoppelt und stieg bis 2006 auf 12
millionen
zuckerberg veränderte facebook erneut
radikal als der 23-jährige ceo
programmierer aus aller welt einlud zu
entdecken zu facebook es war ein
weiterer wendepunkt der facebook von
einer abgeschotteten informationswelt zu
einer plattform ausbaute
es war wie im goldrausch geöffnet diese
wundervolle plattform und alle möglichen
entwickler kommen mit einem möglichen
ideen von video sharing über spiele bis
hin zu dem die linken sich in ballerinas
oder nilpferde verwandeln und einfach
jeder art von lustigen sachen
plattform oder betriebssystem
unternehmen machen das beste ist durch
microsoft hatten diese allgegenwärtigen
raus plattform und all diese anderen
firmen haben programme für windows
geschrieben facebook versucht glücklich
sich der selbst erschafft und
2007 brachte sich microsoft selbst
diesmal mit einem deal in sakkara berg
nicht ablehnen konnte
und zum ersten mal bekam die welt einen
eindruck davon
leute gewöhnen sich daran dass jeder
eine milliarde dollar für facebook
bezahlen würde microsoft kommt und zahl
250 millionen dollar für 1,6 prozent des
unternehmens
das unternehmen wurde damit auf 15
milliarden dollar geschätzt das hat
facebook zu einer sache gemacht über den
alle rede das 15 milliarden dollar
unternehmen aber für 1 15 milliarden
dollar unternehmen machte facebook nur
magere 30 millionen dollar gewinn
um dem abzuhelfen kündigte zuckerberg
ein umfassendes neues werbesysteme ein
teil davon ermöglicht es unternehmen im
herbst 2007 ihre eigenen facebook-seite
nein zurück
lokaler beschäftigt sich mit social
media und besitzt anteile an facebook
auf facebook sind anzeigen in denen
deine freunde mac und das virgin america
mögen und es überrascht nicht dass sie
ist dass seine freunde ein produkt mögen
das duo auf diese anzeige klickt und so
waren diese social apps von anfang an
sehr erfolgreich von der bedenken aber
ein anderer teil des neuen werbe plans
von facebook bieten den nutzern weit
mehr als sie wollten und sie ließen
zuckerberg davon wissen
görg hat viele fehler gemacht bis der
nächste wirklich große fehler barbican
du gehst auf eine e commerce seite eines
dritten täters und kaufte und wenn du
nicht schnellgang gebiss geht es zurück
und führt alle deine freunde darüber
informieren gerade einem diamant
verlobungsring gekauft es gab den riesen
auf schreibt dass facebook weihnachten
ruiniert hat weil plötzlich alle
einkäufe in ihr gesamtes netzwerk
übertragen wurden
wirklich eine weile versucht es zu
verteidigen es dauerte ein bisschen bis
er erkannte wie falsch es war im
dezember 2007 entschuldigte sich
zuckerberg erneut er hatte es wieder mal
übertrieben gern aber wie bei früheren
fehlern würde es nicht wirklich darauf
ankommen war einfach zu beliebt und es
dauerte nicht lange bis auch die
datenschutzbestimmungen des netzwerks
mehr als vier jahre nach der gründung
von facebook fühlte sich zuckerberg in
der öffentlichkeit immer noch
verkaufen sie
keins von dem gerücht los war oder
mir sehr unangenehm
kursierten gerüchte dass facebook an die
börse gehen
stattdessen nahm zuckerberg geld von
einem neuen investor
yuri milner geschäftsführer der
russischen internet investmentfirma
digital sky technologies
er bot einen 200 millionen dollar für
nur 19 prozent des unternehmens seien
geschäfte dieser größenordnung sind nie
einfach ist gleich viel hin und her dass
der diesem deal ging es um die vision
die wir teilchen wie groß dieses
unternehmen werden kann gerd
müllers investition ermöglichte es
facebook weiter zu expandieren er lenkt
die entwicklung des unternehmens fest in
den händen des gründers zu
einer einzigartigen position sei
eben selbst mit den besten werbesystem
die es geht gibt es nur schätzungen
geschlecht alter oder interessen einer
person auf facebook wissen wir genau
und genau
ein unternehmen das aktien- und privat
gehaltene unternehmen vermittelt die
noch nicht am öffentlichen markt
gehandelt
aus sicht der gabe tragenden so
begehrenswert macht ist dass sie wie
kein anderer informationen über ihre
nutzer sein kann das lustige ist dass
die nutzer das nicht wirklich als daten
krachten das sind sie selbst es sind
ihre informationen es ist ihr leben das
sie dort veröffentlichen aber für getan
er ist es der heilige gral geladen
[Musik]
dieses heiligen grabes brachte sascha
berg erneut in schwierigkeiten im
dezember 2009 überarbeitete er die
datenschutz einstellungen für die damals
350 millionen facebook-nutzer wenn die
nutzer ihre einstellungen nicht einzeln
wieder herstellten private informationen
jetzt für alle im internet verfügung
viele leute haben diese vorgabe einfach
übernommen und unbeabsichtigt zugelassen
dass ihre informationen veröffentlicht
werk und viele datenschützer glauben
dass sie das nicht erklärt oder
ausreichend offengelegt haben
ein feuersturm angeschwärzt an sendern
und verbraucherverbänden zwang
zuckerberg erneut zurückziehen und löste
im kongress besorgnis aus wir sind heute
hier um den cio von facebook mark
zuckerberg aufzufordern die neue
richtlinie so schnell wie möglich zu
überdenken wir sind der meinung dass
facebook die richtlinien ändern sollte
damit die nutzer im voraus wissen was
passiert
das feuer noch weiter an instant
messages business insider
veröffentlichte nachrichten in denen ein
freund sascha burg polizei gefragt habe
warum die leute ihre e mails mit ihm
teilten seine antwort
ich habe ihm direkt danach gefragt
weniger als einen monat später wurde er
in einem denkwürdig peinlichen interview
bei der all things digital und die renz
gegrillt haben sie das gefühl die
privatsphäre anderer zu verletzen
wir haben beim aufbau viel gelernt
es gab echte wendepunkte
er nicht damals gewusst hätte was ich
heute weiß dann hätte ich die fehler
wohl nicht gemacht zurück in die
vergangenheit kann nur das tun was sie
für richtig
jeder wer jemals daran gezweifelt hat
worum es bei facebook geht aber seine
integrität in frage stellen wollte kann
sich immer wieder darauf berufen oder
ich kann diesen kerl nicht trauen
es wird unsere kontrolle über ihn sein
solange er ceo bleibt und das
unternehmen leitet es wird heißen ob du
bist mich dieser typ der weiß dass die
nicht dieser typ
[Musik]
beim datenschutz gezielt an die grenzen
in den meisten situationen in denen ein
unternehmen etwas unpopuläres tut gibt
es einen rückschlag und sie verlieren
die fähigkeit etwas zu tun habe aber im
fall von facebook haben wir etwas das
ich bloß vor bord nennen wo sie zwei
schritte nach vorne machen es gibt eine
öffentliche reaktion sie treten nur
einen kleinen schritt zurück und so
können die sie im laufe der zeit über
die profile eröffnung
[Musik]
monarch ist der meinung dass man bei der
arbeit kein anderer mensch sein sollte
als auf der bowlingbahn im bett oder in
der schule er findet dass man in all
diesen umgebungen gleich sein sollte das
ist für viele ältere menschen eine sehr
radikale ansichten
und 20 jahre alt wurde war er so bekannt
mächtig
und die gründung von
diese geschichte begann für mich in
einer e mail die ich aus heiterem himmel
bekannt
gegen seinen ehemaligen klassenkameraden
eingereicht hatte
mit ihm sprach sie haben sich dann im
wesentlichen einig grün und weiß genau
was passiert ist aber ich habe gehört
dass er fünf prozent von facebook hat
und eine vereinbarung unterzeichnen
musste dass er nie wieder mit bert
brecht
durchgesehen
hat gesehen
das drehbuch zu schreiben
die vorab werbung für den film schien
zuckerberg zu einer pr-offensive zu
drängen
der eigentlich so schüchterne zuckerberg
oder plötzlich überall wenn dann etwas
großartiges macht wie interessiert dass
die leute es ist den leuten egal was
jemand in einem film über diesen 2010
gab er oprah winfrey eine führung durch
sein haus und kündigte eine 100
millionen dollar spende an schulen in
newark new jersey
100 millionen
[Applaus]
2010 kam der film das soziale netzwerk
die leute wollen ins internet gehen und
ihre freunde schicken warum also nicht
eine website bauen wie das bietet ich
spreche davon die gesamte soziale
erfahrung der uni zu nutzen und sie
online zu stellen zuckerberg beschwerte
sich allein auf dem bildschirm als
rücksichtsloser sozial behinderter
powervr ikone freunde er sagte es gebe
sachliche fehler im drehbuch
das wäre der grund facebook zu machen
dass sich mädchen treffen will oder in
eine soziale einrichtung einsteigen will
aber die leute die mich kennen wissen
ich bin mit demselben mädchen zusammen
seit ich mit facebook angefangen habe
sie können sich einfach nicht mit der
vorstellung auseinandersetzen dass
jemand etwas bauen könnte weil einfach
gerne dinge baut
[Applaus]
obwohl er anfang sagte er würde sich den
film nicht ansehen kam zuckerberg am
ende mit seiner gesamten belegschaft er
tauchte sogar
jemals den film gesehen
es war interessant
das soziale netzwerk gewann einen golden
globe für das beste drama
dass tunesien jetzt ägypten was kommt
als nächstes
aber für immer mehr menschen auf der
ganzen welt war facebook nicht nur
das beeinflusste das wirkliche leben
ende 2010 gingen demonstranten in
tunesien und später in ägypten auf die
straße um gegen die repressiven
regierungen zu protestieren zu diesem
zeitpunkt lebten mehr als 70 der über
eine halbe milliarde facebook-nutzer
entzündete sich die wut an einem fall
von polizei und alice im mittelpunkt der
proteste stand ein google mitarbeiter
der eine facebook-seite betrieb
war der manager einer seite in ägypten
die ein denkmal für einen typen war der
von der geheimpolizei geschlagen
gefoltert und getötet wurde
und diese gruppe wurde sehr sehr groß
viele viele hunderttausende von
mitgliedern während derzeit die zur
revolte gegen mubarak führte
[Musik]
mit facebook konnten die menschen
schneller ihre unzufriedenheit
ausdrücken was den prozess dieser
revolten deutlich beschleunigte
nachdem die regierungen von tunesien und
ägypten gestürzt waren hatten sich
demonstranten auf den straßen facebooks
einer nannte seine neugeborene tochter
und cnn
ich würde gerne mark zuckerberg treffen
und ihm danken ich spreche im namen des
diese revolution begann auf facebook als
hunderttausende von ägyptern anfingen
informationen zusammen zu bringen
wenn wir ein video auf facebook posten
wurde es innerhalb weniger stunden von
50.000 menschen geteilt
facebook selbst hat versucht sich sehr
schnell von dieser politischen aktivität
zu distanzieren ich denke sie haben voll
unterstützt aber wollen nicht wirklich
als werkzeug dieser veränderung gesehen
facebook offensichtlich auch in ländern
wie china aktiv sein
sie wollen sich nicht als werkzeug des
aufstands
zuckerberg hat sich ein persönliches
ziel gesetzt bei seiner mission die welt
zu verbinden helfen könnte eine stunde
am tag
dabei helfen eine milliarde neue freunde
zu gewinnen es ist der am schnellsten
wachsende und größte internetmarkt der
welt es gibt hunderte millionen von
nutzern und seine mission ist
unvollständig wenn er nicht denn china
ist mark zuckerbergs macht war nie
größer und wieder wuchsen die
spekulationen dass er sein unternehmen
an die börse bringen
100 200 jahren was wird dann wichtiger
sein das geld oder die tatsache dass er
diese art von einfluss hatte oder die
tatsache dass er dieses ding gemacht und
mit entwickelt hat mehr ist das nur eine
technologie sei
und es ist mehr als nur eine website und
deshalb ging es nie um geld
in unternehmen an die börse gehen ist
das eine enorme belastung für das
management und obendrein öffnet man sich
bei einem börsengang noch stärker der
staatlichen kontrolle
um diese kontrolle wissens verstärkte
facebook seine präsenz in moshi einem
team das mehrere ehemalige berater des
weißen hauses und einflussreiche
regierungsintern
politische beamte werden dir sagen wenn
du da der debatte nicht dabei bist wirst
du wahrscheinlich derjenige sein der
irgendwie ausgeschlossen wird
deswegen ist die anwesenheit in dieser
debatte vor allem wenn google yahoo
microsoft und viele andere große akteure
viel geld für lobbyarbeit ausgeben ein
fehler
klassenkameraden das unternehmen
verlassen um sich selbst
aber viele talente aus dem silicon
valley
top programmierer verlassen unternehmen
wie google zum teil von facebook twitter
und facebook und google die beiden
internet giganten mehr konkurrieren auf
andere weise bryan single ist darf
weiter für das magazin sei die beziehung
zwischen facebook und google ist
ziemlich einfach sie mögen sich einfach
nicht sie sind sehr verschieden wissen
sie
war irgendwie jung frech wild
und google ist ihr eine algorithmus
firma das sind typen die sind so für
jedes problem muss es einen weg geben
einen kleinen algorithmus zu schreiben
der es bewegt
es ist klar dass google den aufstieg der
sozialen netzwerke verpasst hat
zugegeben dass er auf verlorenem posten
stellt sie haben eine reihe von dingen
ausprobieren das soziale netzwerk was
das einfach nicht funktioniert im mai
2011 wurde facebook in verlegenheit
gebracht als bekannt wurde dass es einen
geheimen angriff auf google gestartet
hatte
facebook betreibt schadensbegrenzung
nach der enthüllung dass es eine pr
firma beauftragt hat negative
geschichten über google zu verbreiten
ist behauptete öffentlich das sei eine
hetzkampagne dabei der austausch zeigte
die bösartig die konkurrenz geworden die
ganze last hallo katastrophe war
wirklich nur ein offener ausdruck der
feindseligkeit nicht nur zwischen beiden
unternehmen entstanden die queen sondern
fast ein persönliches shakespeare-drama
dass wir zwischen google und facebook
abspielt auch viele ehemalige google
führungskräfte sitzen die nicht so
raketen als ihr früheres unternehmen zu
verbrennen
man kann nicht unterschätzen wie
ehrgeizig mark zuckerberg ist er sagt
seine mission ist es die welt offener
und zu einem besseren ort für seine
mission ist es aber auch die nummer eins
zu sein ich glaube er will auch jeanette
eingraviert sein überlegen
an weiteren harvard aussteiger
zuckerberg ein harter konkurrent im
april 2012 besiegte er mit einer
beeindruckenden übernachtungen rivalen
google und twitter
handumdrehen vom markt facebook markt
die photo sharing app so sehr das ist
vor dem börsengang eine milliarde dollar
in bar und aktien dafür bezahlt aber die
app ist kostenlos und hat kaum bekannte
einnahmen trotzdem braucht facebook
instagram vielmehr als instagram das
geld braucht instagram ist zu einem foto
sharing konkurrenten und einem eigenen
sozialen netzwerk geworden
so kann es nicht riskieren dass ein
anderes soziales netzwerk das auch fotos
ausgerichtet ist eine vergleichbare
anziehungskraft entwickelt
ich glaube dass das eine präventive
qualität hat ja mit ziemlicher
sicherheit auch interessiert und so war
facebook vielleicht gezwungen zu handeln
legte facebook den bisher größten
börsengang eines internetunternehmens
das ist ein großartiger moment
um im kapuzenpulli und turnschuhen
verfügt über 57 prozent der
aktionärsstimmen recht facebook hat
buchstäblich die welt verändert wir sind
vom land über das dorf in die stadt zum
facebook gekommen ich glaube es wird
immer größer und größer und größer
die es geschafft hat sich vom schlafsaal
zu einer plattform zu entwickeln auf der
meine 80 jährige mutter und ich und mein
chiropraktiker und meine dritte klasse
zusammenkommen dann was zu besprechen
haben das ist eine leistung
[Musik]
genau so visionär steve jobs
hat er sich als genauso einflussreich
erweisen wie bill gates wo aber er hat
es nicht mit einem spielzeug zu tun
einem programm
sondern mit unserem leben unserer
identität deshalb glaube ich dass wir
ihm alle in gewisser weise in schach
halten müssen
wir treffen unsere entscheidung bei
facebook nicht mein zu optimieren was im
nächsten jahr passieren würde sondern um
uns darauf vorzubereiten in einer welt
zu leben in der jede produkterfahrung
soziale und alles von facebook angezogen